des sondes qui explorent des mondes
éloigné d'autres qui frôle le soleil la
découverte d'une soeur de la terre 2020
l'année des exploits techniques et de la
recherche de la vie extraterrestre
c'est une quête qui est ce enfin l'un
depuis qu'on a trouvé la toute première
exoplanète dans les années 90
les astrophysiciens lyon lyon comme rêve
de découvrir une terre 2.0 à retenir la
spectaculaire mission osiris rex qui a
pris le vix 400 g de sol sur un rocher
situé à 300 millions de km de la terre
et le retour de la sonde japonaise
hayabusa avec à son bord du matériel
extra terrestres non contaminés et donc
des tas de molécules ou d'état d'acides
aminés qui pourrait résister à cette
rentrée sur terre et dans lequel on va
pouvoir avoir d'informations précieux
sur qu'est ce qui a amené la vie sur une
planète comme la terre des chercheurs
croient par ailleurs avoir trouvé une
forme de vie primitive dans la haute
atmosphère de vénus de la phosphine une
molécule est associée à certaines
bactéries sur terre dans cette couche de
nuages là en altitude
la température est à peu près comme sur
terre la pression est à peu près comme
sur terre il reste l'acide sulfurique
qui est vraiment pas idéal pour la vie
mais on pourrait peut-être imaginer des
formes de vie qui réussira à se protéger
de ce
le satellite européen ka ya aurait
également permis de créer cette carte
exceptionnelle
certes % des 300 milliards dhs étoiles
de notre galaxie en mouvement leurs
positions et leurs distances confirmé ce
7% là il est vraiment fantastique parce
qu'il nous permet de déterminer
correctement la position et d'avoir une
photo 3d de notre galaxie et de voir
l'évolution en fait des étoiles les
courants des toiles qui existe dans
notre galaxie est d'avoir une carte la
plus précise qui existe à ce jour de
notre propre galaxie élégance puissance
fiabilité impossible de passer sous
silence le retour des américains dans
l'espace avec spacek ce la force
montante dans le secteur spatial mais
aussi celui de la chine
la puissance économique hyperactive qui
part maintenant à la conquête de la lune
il faut aussi rappeler la perte du grand
radiotélescope d'arecibo utilisé durant
plusieurs décennies pour tenter sans
succès de détecter des signaux radio
extraterrestre mais ce n'était pas son
unique d'âge c'est le télescope qui a
permis la détection des toutes premières
exoplanètes pas autour d'une étoile
similaire au soleil mais autour d'un
pulsar qui est un cadavre stellaire donc
c'était une découverte très surprenante
qui s'est fait en 1991 à surveiller en
la mission martienne persévérance un
roumain un drone
coût de questions en suspens sa saveur
fondamentale pour savoir si la vie a
réellement existé sur mars et essayer de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé si entre
le moment où la vie existe et où elle a
disparu ici normand grandin radio canada
montréal